proved tragically accurate
president putin of russia has unleashed
war in our european continent
he's attacked a friendly country
without any provocation
and without any credible
excuse
innumerable missiles and bombs have been
raining down on an entirely innocent
population
a vast invasion is underway by land
by sea
and by air and this is not in the
infamous phrase some far away country of
which we know little
we have ukrainian friends in this
country neighbors
co-workers
ukraine is a country that for decades
has enjoyed freedom and democracy
and the right to choose its own destiny
we
and the world
cannot allow that freedom just to be
snuffed out
we cannot and will not
just look away
it's because we've been so alarmed in
recent months that
russian intimidation that the uk became
one of the first countries in europe to
send defensive weaponry to help the
ukrainians
other allies have now done the same and
we will do what more we can in the days
ahead
today
in concert with our allies we will agree
a massive package of economic sanctions
designed in time to hobble the russian
economy
and to that end we must also
collectively cease the dependence on
russian oil and gas that for too long
has given putin his grip on western
politics
our mission
is clear
diplomatically politically economically
and eventually military this hideous and
barbaric venture
of vladimir putin must end
in failure
and so i say to the people of russia
whose president has just authorized a
tidal wave of violence against a fellow
slavic people
as the parents of russian soldiers who
will lose their lives
i cannot believe this is being done in
your name
or that you really want the pariah
status it will bring to the putin regime
now i say to the ukrainians in this
moment of agony
we're with you
we're praying for you and your families
and we are on your side
and if the months ahead are grim and the
flame of freedom burns low
i know
that it will blaze bright again in
ukraine because
for all his bombs and tanks and missiles
i don't believe that the russian
dictator will ever subdue the national
feeling of the ukrainians
and their passionate belief that their
country should be free
i say to the british people and all who
have heard the threats from putin
against those who stand with ukraine
we will of course
do everything
to keep our country safe
we're joined in our outrage by friends
and allies around the world we will work
with them for however long it takes to
ensure that the sovereignty and
independence of ukraine is restored
because this act of wanton and reckless
aggression
is an attack not just on ukraine
it's an attack on democracy and freedom
in eastern europe
and around the world
this crisis
is about the right of a free sovereign
independent european people to choose
their own future
and that is a right
that the uk
will always defend
so the prime minister boris johnson
there in his statement to the nation
responding to russia's decision to
launch a major military assault on
ukraine let's get some instant reaction
to it our political editor beth rigby is
in westminster and strong words there
from the prime minister beth he said our
worst fears have now come true president
putin has unleashed war on our european
continent
yes the prime minister there confirming
that he was woken uh shortly after 4 00
a.m to be told that there was now a
full-scale invasion of the ukraine in
what could be the largest conflict in
europe since
1945 so these really are grave and dark
times and the prime minister there what
was his message there were a few things
in that
first was
an acknowledgement about the gravity of
the situation he said our worst fears
have now come true putin of russia has
unleashed a war in our european content
missiles and bombs raining down on an
innocent population a vast invasion
underway he then went on to
reassure uh allies and ukrainians uh
that the uk will not look away he said
we cannot and will not just look away he
then went on to talk about what more the
uk intends to do we've seen this across
europe and obviously the us as well he
talked about more sanctions he said
there would be a massive package of
sanctions designed to hobble the russian
economy the prime minister will be
making a statement in the commons later
today where no doubt he will
expand on that and in the eu they are
also agreeing a packet of sanctions so
this will be coordinated across
nato and across european allies he then
said to the ukrainian people
if the months ahead are grim and the
flame of freedom burns low we will make
sure it blazes bright again he then said
to the british people we will do
everything to keep our country safe he
said we will work to ensure that the
sovereignty and independence of ukraine
is
restored but he also warned that this
could as he said earlier in the week
that this could be a protracted uh and
bloody invasion that could go on uh for
a long time for many months he said it's
not just an attack on ukraine but an
attack on
democracy and the uk will always defend
the principle of democracy so the prime
minister there standing
side by side with the ukrainian
president with uh the people of ukraine
and with nato allies in terms of what it
means uh in the coming days those
economic sanctions will come
but also questions now clearly about
what additional military assistance
might be given uh to ukraine by nato
allies already some mps david davis uh
the former leadership contender former
cabinet minister uh saying this morning
uh that it's time for nato to give air
support uh to ukraine in light of the
russian uh invasion incursion and that
could be under discussion later today in
the house of commons
beth thanks very much indeed
so let's take a look at what we know so
far what's been happening in ukraine
over the last few hours president putin
said he has begun a special military
operation in the donbas in eastern
ukraine
but within minutes of that announcement
multiple explosions were heard in
ukraine's capital kiev
there were also explosions heard in the
city of kharkiv in the northeast of
ukraine
ukraine's emergency service has reported
shelling in the western city of levive
which is only 70 kilometers from the
border with poland
multiple blasts have been heard near the
city of mariopol in the south east where
reuters journalists have seen tanks
which they say appear to belong to
ukrainian military heading towards the
city
ukraine's border guard agency said the
russian military attacked from
neighboring belarus and that russia has
been moving military equipment from
annexed crimea into ukraine
well a short while ago the regional
authority in the port city of odessa
said there had been a missile attack
there
well there are now reports of civilian
fatalities 18 people are reported to
have been killed in that missile strike
in odessa in southern ukraine
at least six have been killed in
brauravi on the western outskirts of
kiev
and ukrainian emergency services say a
boy has been killed in kharkiv in
eastern ukraine after shelling hit a
block of flats
so let's just show you the scene now in
kiev where the authorities are
considering their next move there have
been some reports of explosions being
heard in the capital city and also
reports of
use of traffic of people trying to leave
we have heard in the last hour from jens
stoltenberg the
nato secretary general as well
who has had some stern words of
condemnation in response to this russian
action he called it a grave moment for
the security of europe so let's get more
now on the reaction to russia's move
debra haynes our defense and security
editor is in kiev for us now
so deborah give us a sense of what we
know so far of the military situation on
the ground there in ukraine
well in terms of right here in the
centre of kiev it's